وحلفائنا على حد سواء
فيما يتعلق بعمليه من السودان متى تم
تيسير
القافله ثالثه هل كان هناك ثلاث قوائف في
قافله فقط
اذا القافله الاولى يوم السبت
القافلتين الثاني والثالثه يوم الاحد
ساعطيك التاريخ المحدد ولكن
القافله الثالثه وصلت في وقت مبكر اليوم
الى بورسودان ادرك انه كان انكم لا تريدون
اعطاء ارقام ولكن لا ارى يمكن ان يكون ذلك
مشكله ما هو عدد المواطنين الامريكيين او
الذين يحوزون الاقامه الامريكيه قد حصلوا
على المساعده من
السلطات القنصليه لا استطيع ان اعطيك
اجابه
دقيقه لذلك فمنذ بدا اعمال العنف
اتفهم سؤالك اذا الجواب هو كلب ولكن يجب
ان نتذكر ان جده ليست المكان الوحيد ان
اطرح عليك السؤال ان اتفهم هذا السؤال انا
لا اسالك عن جده
لديكم ارقام بعدد المواطنين الذين تم
اجلائهم هذه عمليه لا تزال متواصله اذن من
الواضح انكم لا تريدون الاجابه على هذا
السؤال تفضل
الارقام تم
تناقلها بشكل واسع ما هو تقييمكم في الوقت
الراهن بشان عدد الامريكيين الذين يحتاجون
في الوقت
اراها
لمساعده السلطات الامريكيه لمغادره
السودان ليس هناك اي عدد محدد يمكن ان
اعطيه لك
فالمواطنين الامريكيون يتخذون القرار بشان
مغادره السودان في الوقت وحسب الايلات
التي تناسبهم
هو اننا توصلنا خلال هذه الازمه ما اكثر
من خمسه الاف مواطن امريكي منذ بدا مال
العنف استطعنا ان نجلي بامان حوالي 1000
مواطن امريكي وقد اشرت الى ان هناك ثلاث
قوافل نقلت ما اكثر من 700 شخص وهؤلاء لا
يظهرون في عدد المواطن الذين تم اجلؤهم
اذن ما هو عدد المواطنين الامريكيين من
بين هؤلاء الاشخاص السبعمائه الذين تم
اجلاؤهم ليس لدي عدد محدد بشانهم اشرتم
الى خمسه الاف ثم تقولون الان الرقم هو
الف هل لكم ان تحددوا لنا ما هي الارقام
الدقيقه بشان المواطنين الامريكي او من
تبقى منهم في السودان
ينبغي ان نتذكر هميره بانه ليس كل
المواطنين الامريكيين الذين وصلوا الى
امنه انهم
لم يعودوا مدرجين ضمن قوائم الاشخاص الذين
يريدون الاجلاء وبالتالي نستطيع نعطيك
ارقاما محدده بهذا الشهر بناء عما تفضلت
به حتى الان
عدد 700
ضمن عمليات الاجلاء التي تمت منذ يوم
السبت اذا 700
متضامن ضمن الالف شخص ليس لدي اي ارقام
محدده بشان المواطنين الامريكيين وغيرهم
الذين يحملون الجنسيات الاخرى الذين تم
اجلائهم من السودان اشرت الى القافله
الثانيه
منذ بدا العمل عنف وتشديداتها استطعنا ان
نجلي حوالي 1000 مواطن امريكي من خلال
اليات اخرى مثل الرحلات التي ينظمها
شركاؤنا وكذلك عبر قوافل تنظمها المنظمات
الدوليه اذن نحن نعطيكم هذه الارقام وفقا
اما يصلنا ولكن بينما يتواصل المواطنين
امريكيون
بالمصالح القنصليه
نستطيع ان نعطي ارقاما مدققه اشرت الى 700
700 شخص وانا افترض ان يوجد بينهم مواطن
امريكيين هذا صحيح
الرقم الذي اعطيته لكم سوف يرتفع بناء على
ذلك
تفضلي
المواطن العدد الف او المواطن الامريكي
الذين بلغ عددهم الف وتم اجلائهم من
السودان ومن خلال عمليات الاجلاء بمساعده
الشركاء هل
يمكن ان تؤكدوا في الطريقه التي تم
اجلاؤهم بها هل هي بر او عبر وسائل اخرى
الوضع متغير بشكل كبير
ونحن نواصل تقديم المعلومات قدر على
المستطاع ولدي سؤال اخر
يعني بعض السفن في بورت السودان
التقرير بشانها
سعتها هي دون عشرين بالمئه هل لكم علم
بالمواقع الامريكيين الذين ربما تم
اجلائهم على متن هذه السفن ليست لديها
معلومات محدده يمكن ان اعطيها لك ما اود
ان الاحظه ان
القوافل التي قمنا بتنظيمها لم تكون
مكتمله الاعداد لان الوضع الامني متغير
جدا واستطعنا ان ننقل الاشخاص الذين تمكنا
من اجلائهم ولكنني لست على علم بهذه
الحاله الخاصه التي اشرت اليها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات